hello my name is Karen Warren with la
talk radio's film courage i'm here at
the 6th annual san diego indie fest and
i'm here with mr. Craig Wilson of mental
arctic air tell us how did you get
involved with indie fest well that's
kind of a long story I've known about
any fest for a while and so I was trying
to get in just even volunteer and I
couldn't get ahold of Danielle the
executive producer and I actually ran
into her in the hallways with us in this
event there in this venue for something
else and we shook hands and they had the
film festival all rolling there was
another company they plan on doing like
a two-day Film Festival 50 films which
is about 10 times more films than
they've ever done in the past and a
couple days after I met her she calls me
up and says hey Craig the other company
just they had to back out and it was six
weeks before the event I'm like can you
guys step in and we talked it over a
little bit I know what my duties were
and I said yeah I'll mobilize timo and
we made it all happen so yeah I just
kind of fell into my lap you're a
filmmaker though why not just make films
why why get involved with planning
events and worried about
panels and red carpet interviews and all
that well I am still I I'm gonna have a
lot of films going and I'm very DIY so
originally when I started I've got a a
monthly screening series when I
originally started that it was only
supposed to get was supposed to act as a
means for distribution for myself
because I find out branding it here and
in Los Angeles and we had a company in
Seattle it's interesting doing it kind
of spreading it and then that way I kind
of and when I made a film I had my own
distribution to put out there I'm also a
huge huge supporter of indie everything
indie filmmakers and I try to create
whatever tools or be a part of whatever
tools that can help them and i'm also
really large into the san diego very
passionate from God I did my name i did
my stay in LA so things like events like
this and some of the other ones are
putting on is really to get the San
Diego filmmakers to come out and talk
and network and meet and you know I
whatever I can do to help support the
local community can you can you talk
about the opportunities that I've opened
up for you because of your outreach
efforts oh yeah I've gotten well i mean
this this came about honestly and after
i told Daniel a little bit about what I
was doing already should I go well that
fits perfectly because have you talked
with the other company and get involved
in when they stepped out we stepped in
so that kind of opened up and that for
this I can't go into details but I bet
there's two other projects coming up
that are even higher higher profile than
this all happening in San Diego which is
it's it's pretty cool and people are
taking extra interest now and the work
that anybody within my company is doing
so yeah it's I have so many resources in
san diego and
the community here is very collaborative
let's get together and make a film
you